hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to rains now when I played
sort the court a lot of you guys told me
that it was a lot like this game here
and in fact I want to play sort the
court again because there's been a
massive update to the game that adds
more interactions new characters new
goals and even an ending that actually
is there so I'm gonna be playing that
again but I wanted to play this first
because I wanted to get a good idea of
what this one was all about and also
Wade played it and seemed like he had
some fun with it
so anyway who are you the King know what
happens if I say no hello no I only talk
to the king if you're not the king I'm
going back to sleep okay good night the
spirit looks at you thoughtfully then
disappears you enter the throne room
the throne room okay so what about that
coming out oh I do have a mouse okay
oh okay I didn't know what that was I'm
not good at this oh I'm not good at this
yet
hey everybody hold on alright so this is
weird so there's no clicking involved
okay
the King of the West is offering us
money to buy a small part of the country
says John Cromwell the King of the West
I thought I was the only King I don't
bow down to no king
I am The King I'm the only King my lord
God brush loose tongue managed to set a
lion loose in the streets of the capital
it's pandemonium send the army close the
castle gates I mean if we close the
castle gates isn't that just gonna
create a death pit with a lion in the
middle or maybe it's not gonna be able
to escape seems like a rather
extravagant use of the entire army just
close the gates they'll sort it out come
on come on come on Lady Grey rah okay an
earthquake destroyed a large part of the
capital the city guard awaits your
orders prevent pillaging or save the
victims ah
well me no likey pillaging so don't do
that no one's gonna take advantage of
this situation
what oh you your people are famished and
unrest is spreading what what I have no
idea
Oh God the castle is ransacked your
Court disperses and you're left with
pigeons to rule over oh oh I'm dead ah
[ __ ] nut did I die that quickly was IA
terrible King was that really all that
bad
I mean if you guys think about it if you
really weigh your options could I have
been that horrible yeah I was I was
probably terrible that I didn't know how
to do this
okay Portrait Gallery whoa one of 26
deaths suffered ohh ooh governed at
least like I did I didn't even govern at
least 5 years I am a big old bag of
dicks aren't I I am oh boy I'm Louie
okay let's try this again now that I
know how to play Oh King Harry alrighty
then well that first king was an [ __ ]
no one aghhh ignore that it's hello
everybody my name is Henry I'm here to
be here are you the young king ah not
again just kidding I know we've already
been through this that's our curse see
uh I don't understand we will remember
each and every king in this dynasty
every compromise every death for ages oh
well that's no good it is sad that only
the devil will allow us to blissfully
forget the curse of kings but does he
even exist I mean probably not
that's an interesting lack of faith I
would love to be free though not me I
like being king the spirit slowly drifts
away all right let's see if I can stop
being such a bag of dicks and actually
live longer than five years all right
the Kingdom of the South claims that
your betrothed to their young princess
declining may trigger war ah yeah I'm
gonna put a big no on that one because I
don't think anybody cares no I'm not
marrying nobody til I see them so no ha
ha there's war would you like to play a
red dwarf my lord let's start with a
small bet I don't want to ruin you again
these things that I don't understand
I play fine dice are rolling I'm pretty
sure I won you don't want to raise the
stakes while you still can
oh yeah well [ __ ] you dude
do this Oh dye bras loose tongue slowly
lifts the gobbler revealing two dice
okay odd I won care to play how does
that mean you didn't even explain the
rules to me guy boss loose tongue let's
play again yeah let's do that pretty
sure I won all right I raise you sir I
raised again I have to bet the trick oh
I raised Oh what wait oh wait hang on a
sec Oh your work your what your country
is ruined my lord merchants and nobility
own everything what what Oh God
Oh the new oligarchy forces you to exile
for dickbag of a Henry gambled the
entire kingdom away what a loser
oh he's being eaten by spiders and crabs
are those crabs okay well that sucked
well the King's dead he lived less long
last king I am I'm an even bigger bag of
dicks than the last one
next the ghost is gonna tell me yes it
is our curse of the Kings we eat shall
be resurrected as an even bigger bag of
dicks all right one of these days I'll
get five years as a cholera outbreak in
the capital it's blue death at least
it's not black death alright fine man
could we dismember guy bras loose tongue
please this clown broke down a trebuchet
I brought his tongue I know that man
I was playing tennis with a giant he won
let's see hey the army hey the army we
can never be too prepared you need to
recruit more soldiers okay sounds good
to me we would like to raise a new tax
for the church shared with the crown of
course no may I say hum a young woman
claims that her son is in fact your
bastard should we make this problem
disappear well I mean I've got patented
evidence that I no one would touch me
because I keep dying and making terrible
decisions yes
you never hear from the woman again I
don't know if I ever heard from her in
the first place your people are famished
and unrest is spreading what oh god oh
god damn it I just want to survive five
years I can't I can't be this bad at
this is the right choice I thought this
was gonna be like random chance Oh oops
okay all right then we're gonna my lord
what about a bit of fencing I'm a good
teacher
let's bet a bit of money well knowing my
history with gambling I'd say you're on
and you're gonna eat my dust you will
dance in hell and I will laugh to wait
with you I will ha ha
this one will be difficult to parry be
careful you two
hell yeah you one my lord beginner's
luck do you want to know how to improve
as if I'm not already the best I'm okay
I'm good see we would like to build
school in the capital for the
enlightenment of the people I like
schools schools are cool the miners are
refusing to dig in the mine they want to
raise those dirty rotten miners with the
name of puck want a raise
how about no dig harder the kingdom of
the south claims it Oh God not these
guys again now show me a picture first
paint me something the river drop is
flooding a large part of the country we
need help from the church in the army
okay I understand now so I've got to
keep the things at the top of the list
balanced and let them not hit zero-sum
decisions make it go up some decisions
make it go down and its strategy so it's
not random chance like I thought it was
we need help from the church and the
army all right oh god no the eastern
barony czar at a war again and their
population is crossing our frontier as
we speak come on in yeah
governed five years I finally did it we
should attack the kingdom of the south
they're growing stronger every day you
know what screw those [ __ ] they keep
wanting me to marry their daughter I
don't want that all of them collectively
they have one daughter and they be true
themselves to me kill those bastards I'm
sister Pauline the headmistress of the
new school help us nurture the young
Souls sure okay oh god I'm out of money
cereals are very cheap these days milord
you should adjust the price of bread
double it indeed ship has been
quarantined it may be the plague shall
we quarantine the whole port no other
ship was presented with the disease
we're safe hey I took a gamble on the
lives of my people and everything's okay
alright keep an eye on that there are
too many people to execute I need help
oh jeez how many whoa justice jest holy
[ __ ]
you want to calm down they're a freakin
Judge Dredd over here why are you
killing so many people uh we don't have
army to spare but I don't have people to
spare either so sure oh jeez Vikings are
attacking us we should defend our
kingdom from the north
uh defend ha ha whoa that was close I
would like to spend justice yes I would
like to spend some time studying
horticulture at the school thank you
good god victory the Vikings are
defeated should we exterminate all the
prisoners I mean why the [ __ ] not
oh [ __ ] god damn it my military the
harvest has been fantastic milord oh
hell yeah we should create a Museum of
Science to collect all living creatures
I can help in my spare time Wow justice
gesture is turning a new leaf over here
I I can't believe this is the same guy
that executed half my population ok
justice Jess we got the money the
harvest is a nightmare people are
famished
please sire decrease the taxes how dare
you
dare you whoo-hoo how dare you even
insinuate that I should alright if I do
that what oh I did not know that it was
going to be doing that okay is is a big
circle of plus and a little circle a
minus or do I have to guess what they're
gonna do weird strange noises of the
castle last night we should have more
guards patrolling no we don't have the
money to spare a covenant of nuns has
started meowing like cats it's spreading
to the village I don't see a problem
here meowing nuttin seems like an
entertaining the night why would I care
I in fact I don't care the nuns kept
meowing for ages in the end the church
declared them heretics and burnt down
the Covenant was good thing they got
eight lives left
boink okay the King of the West has been
informed of the state of our army and is
now attacking us retreat and regroup
hell yeah we need to build a new church
how about we don't have the goddamn
money
we already had a covenant burnt to the
ground I'm not gonna build another one
just have it burnt down too no oh oh oh
I'm still alive though a new farming
ticking tick tick tick tick deke has
considered him has considerably improved
Hooked on Phonics work for me what do
you want to do with this income it's
mine all nine it seems my advice is not
to your liking
you know who rules above men and kings
I'm sorry
oopsie-doopsie you P pally sorry I
repent the war is long and painful call
for a ceasefire no no what are you
talking about I'm not tired will the
army hit you lead the last remnants of
your army and die on the steps of the
throne
oh what a tragic end to a tragic tale of
[ __ ] alrighty then
hey but at least I'll at least I lived
almost as long as I've been alive now
hey what is that
it's that symbol there try the blue one
recruit the doctor meet the devil I
don't know what any of that means
what is all that what is that you have
neither curse nor spell nor magical item
what is that I gotta get to that symbol
who I got to survive a little longer
give us enough power to enforce the
divine justice in your country the Pope
is ready to pay the prize sure money oh
hell yeah
my lord you are Saint the Pope wants to
establish his estates here sure dammit
the Pope's armies are taking control of
our holy country this is heaven on earth
what what okay that didn't go as planned
it was going great so you can't let them
reach the top of the thing either I
lasted two fricking years and I didn't
get to the symbol okay gonna try this
again try the blue one okay the fortress
is too weak we should build a tower you
agree or beautiful Capitol smells of
garbage half the year let's build a
sewer system oh you agree you should
organize a curve you the streets of the
capital nine are not safe nay I saw it
was all my progress and no money do you
need some credit my lord eight thousand
gold pieces a five percent interest yes
peasants are revolting large groups of
people are ransacking the capital your
RV is overwhelmed reinforce the owe me
[ __ ] would you like to marry the young
princess of a neighboring kingdom
finally someone asks me what I want
hell yes I hope she's pretty my lord
it's time to pay your debt you are dead
your dad this is the twentieth century
my lord we should celebrate
okay Lady Grey are you
you my wife okay the folks of a remote
village of teaching their children to
spit on the king's men should we make an
example let them spit everybody spits
it's probably a misunderstanding the
river drop is dry again we should build
a dam no cuz that could end terribly Wow
oh hey oh it's a blooper oh I agree
What did he say we should create a
pilgrimage to the tomb of Saint Armand
do I really have time for that
no I have a gift for you and one of my
Oh God
eeny meeny miny moe catch a tiger by the
toe blah blah blah blah blah Blee blah
Blee Bloo gives you a golden cross then
he runs away shrieking okay thank you
this bloody jester stole our cross but
what is this in your hand see aa state
property no one will suspect a thing
my law the good doctor just saved the
life of my nephew he's a bit of a
magician he's here now
sure let him in I want to see him oh I'm
a doctor Alchemist prisoner I can hear
okay I can handle life for dare you or
death occasionally focus on the life
part because I think the church is about
to kill me the people are Yap here they
go murdered you during your escape
attempt oh I'm dead gerald the wise is
now Gerald the dead but across the
threshold over something and I recruited
a doctor so that's good so what is this
I did something okay so anyway that's
all the time I got for rains this is
actually a lot of fun I might play more
of this I'm also gonna play more sort
the court of the updated version of that
but I want to do another episode on this
this is actually pretty cool I want to
get to that guy over there and try to
fight another king over there so it's
gonna be fun so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]